[Music]
um
so
so
[Music]
um
[Music]
hey here we are once again do you have
the do you have the audio on that i can
hear it
let me turn this [ __ ] down yeah turn
this [ __ ] down
celtic angel says uh she she set her
alarm so she could be here
yeah yeah i don't even know this [ __ ]
was scheduled man [ __ ] jenny keeps
track all this [ __ ] every
well i know because i keep telling us
like look every sunday monday tuesday
wednesday
we do a three o'clock we do a sidetracks
or a mad day i mean you know
i was uh that's not hard to keep track
of i was watching a free
movie on youtube it was free for me i
had i pay for youtube i got that i think
it's called youtube red isn't it
or youtube yeah or something like that i
don't remember what it is cobra kai was
on there and had to buy it
they had they had one on their planet
for free called
uh daylight's end i think is what was
going on i've heard of that yeah it's
pretty good
it's all right yeah yeah it was uh it's
definitely
kind of an homage to to um
mad max the early mad max yeah and road
warrior
and um omega man and escape from new
york
it's like post-apocalyptic they got some
kind of like a
mutant virus kind of turns him into
like a vampire cross between a zombie to
vampire i guess a vampire
vampire they're like a rage
zombie but they can't go out into the
[ __ ] sun that kills them
okay if you get bit you turn into one
but they had a lot of cool guns on there
and
the first the beginning of it i thought
was better until they started adding a
bunch of dialogue
it's not like everyone stop talking
[Laughter]
well it's not like the acting was bad
they actually had good acting in it
had the the black dude from terminator 2
remember the [ __ ] guy who worked for
cyberdyne
yeah yeah oh yeah yeah yeah he was i
can't remember that actor's name
i had the guy who played bishop in
[ __ ] aliens too he was in it
and they gave those guys a lot of
dialogue because because they're
well known i guess yeah like i said it
wasn't bad
it's just that with that type of movie
like omega man and mad max and the whole
appeal is that there's not a whole lot
of dialogue
yeah it's like one thing happening after
another
and every time they start getting into
dialogue to try to flesh out characters
you're like
hold on why are we fleshing out
characters that's what it's vibrant we
the more they're fleshed out the less we
[ __ ] care about them
because that's really the really how
those kind of movies go
you know fast edit is supposed to be up
to your imagination who these guys are
you're supposed to know who they are by
what they're doing not what they're
saying
you know i see it as filler i would have
just taken the movie
and probably edited about 15 minutes of
dialogue out of it and it would have
[ __ ] had a lot better
you should see it i don't know you
probably wouldn't like it it's
i have heard of it so it can't be that
obscure okay
i mean i just haven't i haven't gotten
around to watching a lot of good gun
fights cool guns cool equipment
you know survivalist guys and gangs
and [ __ ] the main characters kind of
like a mad max type guy
got his [ __ ] suppressed m14 a bunch
of cool gear
and he's got a [ __ ] a 1972 amx all
[ __ ]
armored up kind of like max and the
[ __ ]
and his [ __ ] little thunder shark i
forgot what that [ __ ] car is called
the xb falcon that's what it was kind of
like that
you know although the car makes an
appearance in the beginning it's a
rattle trap it makes a big
appearance in the beginning but then
eventually you don't see it anymore you
know it's they kind of left the car
hanging
there wasn't any [ __ ] car action
you know like chases and [ __ ] there
should have been but i don't think they
had it in the budget
yeah mostly just like a uh the tone
was more like a walking dead than mad
max a lot of times
yeah but i recommended it to people on
tom shitty movies and getting sent the
leak if you guys want to see it
what bad i do kind of look through the
free youtube movies sometimes because
every now and then they have like a
really good
uh good one in there like i said i was
very excited a few months ago to found
that the secret of nem on there and i
was like ooh i want to watch that that
animated movie
uh sanders was very glad that i hadn't
poisoned you last night
[Laughter]
i wouldn't do such a thing um and then
they were talking about robert blake
because deborah said that she
uh had seen something with a young
robert blake and how you kind of looked
like
yeah yeah people used to say that a lot
yeah um
and he yeah he actually was uh arrested
for the
murder of his wife yeah bonnie lee
bakely
but uh he got acquitted honestly sure he
i don't know because i i wrote about
that case
for my book and
i don't know it just seems like i mean
yeah it's super fishy
that it was like that he went back into
things like oh i forgot my gun in the
restaurant or whatever he left it in the
booth
and then he came back and she was dead
but the his gun and the gun that shot
her were two different guns yeah his was
on fire
um you know they i'm not saying that he
might not have paid somebody to do it
but
i don't know it's to me it just seems
like it might have just been
i don't know there's actually uh
some [ __ ] that was kind of fishy about
one of shad's wife's when she she was
found dead
wasn't him she was found dead floating
was it william and then he [ __ ]
called
he [ __ ] called the damn my wife was
dead in the pool
and you could tell he's like he's axing
he's kind of acting
and he's like he's like on the star trek
pretty sure it was shot in the [ __ ] out
you guys correct my wife's wrong she's
dead yeah she's dead
in the pool oh my god jim yeah
[Laughter]
star trek oh [ __ ] i think it was william
i do remember hearing something about
that vaguely but i can't remember like i
don't want to say yeah it was william
shatter but it's like yeah he found her
dead floating in the pool
and uh turns out she was on a bunch of
pills
and she must have fallen asleep while
she was like on a damn
raft yeah and somehow you know it's a
little [ __ ] inflatable races
and somehow [ __ ] drowned while she
was in the pool or it was some kind of
suicide they don't know
she was out there for a few hours and i
think it was shat man from correctly she
found her and [ __ ] called 9-1-1 and
sure enough she was
dead she was dead but uh i mean
accidents do happen
so yeah yeah yeah it's just that his
call to 9-1-1
it was it sounded [ __ ] awful hokey
but you don't know if that's just
because that's what he sounds like yeah
i don't know
you don't know because you would hate to
say that there was some [ __ ] about
insurance i think or she had a long drug
problem and he was going to divorce her
and that and that he probably
lost a lot of money and it was i just
remember that back in those days we're
talking i think this was early 80s if i
remember correctly
it was considered fishy back then but i
think it's just forgotten
well anytime anybody turns up dead
floating in a pool
that's always kind of fishy yeah and he
was there at home with her
like all day yeah he she just went out
to the pool on her own
and he was doing his own thing and then
[ __ ] he went out there
that weird no it's not that weird it's
just
but like i said i need to sound weird
anytime that happens and that's like
that's really horrifying because like i
said accidents do happen in fact i'm
reading a book right now
that uh is like a mystery i'm gonna be
reviewing it like in a couple weeks on
my tomes and terror show
but um you ever said yeah it is
shatner's wife yeah i thought yeah i
thought it might have been
yeah but uh where this woman like
seemingly
tripped on a like a vacuum cleaner thing
and like fell down the stairs and broke
her neck
and um you know everybody thought it was
an accident but the thing is accidents
like that do happen all the time
but whenever that kind of thing happens
where well maybe somebody pushed her
maybe somebody like drugged her and put
her in the pool or whatever
it's like there's always anything that
you ever said to that person
anything that anybody ever like had to
gain from that person being dead
is gonna be [ __ ] inspected and it's
like
even if it was just an accident even if
she was just a dummy and she like just
tripped and fell down the stairs
[ __ ] i've fallen downstairs lots of
times not at this house but
because we don't have stairs at this
house but uh in the
house i lived in the uk the stairs were
carpeted and really narrow and
i used to fall down that like every
other day so you know
good thing that was carpet otherwise i
probably would have broken my neck as
well
and it would have been an accident
because i'm just a [ __ ] klutz
[Laughter]
but yeah so i was thinking about another
like uh
person being found dead in a pool case
that i wrote that actually happened in
britain
that i was writing about for my book too
it was like a famous guy
not like not famous over here but famous
over there like nobody over here knows
who the [ __ ] he is but he was like kind
of a big like tv presenter like game
show host or something like that
and this guy they they picked up this
guy at like a nightclub
and he invited him back to his mansion
like for a party there was a bunch of
other people too it was like a party
and uh you know they were all all the
drugs all the booze all the everything
and then uh he ended up dead in the pool
too
and everybody's like we don't know what
happened man he just must have like
taken all the drugs and then fallen into
the pool and drowned
um but it was kind of fishy because they
hadn't called the cops for like two
hours afterward
um it looked like they somebody had like
stuck something up his butt
so you know what i mean like it looked
like he'd been anally raped by an object
um so they don't know if that was
consensual or they don't know you know
what i mean they don't really know what
was going on
so uh yeah that was kind of and i can't
remember the dude's name even though i
wrote about it a little while back but
you know so uh yeah after we uh
did the show last night we were actually
going to because i was gonna
i have a couple like new movies that i
want to watch that i want to like do a
matinee on
um but we didn't really i mean we
weren't that we weren't as drunk as we
were like the week before where it's
like i just went in the room and took a
tiny bite out of a sandwich and just
fell asleep and didn't remember anything
um i was i had pretty much sobered up by
the time we got back in there
but i didn't really want to watch a new
movie so we said we'll just do a
sidetrack show and just talk about
whatever
we just watched some more of the stand i
didn't realize
that was actually only four it was four
episodes but the episodes were like two
hours each so this thing is like
eight hours long is it eight hours long
i think or
six this might be six to eight hours
yeah it's just weird because i mean
we're watching like dominic sent us the
um
the blu-ray and so we just put it on
like watch the whole thing so it's not
really it doesn't do credits it doesn't
do anything like that it's just like is
playing the whole thing like uh
like a movie um pretty much the only
time you know that that's a new episode
is when the little title comes up and
because you know that
they have four different titles like so
we're we're at the part
now which is the third part which i
think is called the betrayal
and we're right at the part where they
all
were all like the good people all got
together and are going out to
colorado right yeah i was surprised to
watch the movie how workmanlike the
movie is it goes right through it it's
it's real close to the book well stephen
king wrote the teleplay
yeah the funny thing about it is i was
reading about it on wikipedia earlier
and what i didn't realize was that they
have been they had been trying to get
an adaptation of the stand off the
ground since the 70s because like the
book came out in 1978
and they pretty much like stephen king
and george romero
were interested in doing like a movie of
it
and there was a couple like uh you know
hollywood execs and stuff that were
really into that idea
and so it went through like so many
different iterations
stephen king wrote the [ __ ] treatment
and the treatment ended up being like
eight hours long yeah you can't make
that into it and
yeah and then they were like well that
obviously isn't gonna fly and then they
kind of went back and forth
and actually when they made creep show
in 1985
that was supposed to be like that was
supposed to like
fund like oh thank you thank you xanada
thank you very much hope you guys had a
good weekend we did yeah
um that was kind of supposed if that was
successful that was kind of supposed to
fund this
but so the fact that they had been
talking about doing it since like
1979 1980 and didn't get around to doing
it until 1994
is [ __ ] crazy and i didn't even know
this but they asked dario argento to
direct it
um what he was one of the first
directors
do you see where they copied dario
agento in a lot of the shows yeah and he
was like well i don't really like doing
adaptations of other people's work
generally
although he did later on like he did
phantom of the opera and [ __ ] but um
yeah so he didn't really want to do it
worked out didn't it well the fan of the
opera one wasn't
terrible uh the dracula one was terrible
yeah but that wasn't really even an
adaptation i don't even know what the
[ __ ] that was
[ __ ] that was crazy that's what i was
actually thinking that was the dracula
one no he didn't
i don't think you've seen phantom of the
opera i have to say i mean i love dario
look
like he's one of my favorite filmmakers
but i don't
really like anything after this ghost
fit
i love you know what i still really like
the stendal syndrome which i think came
out in the 90s 96 i want to say
um that's actually on to be i think for
free or it's on shutter i can't remember
because i just watched it not too long
ago i'm like hey this is actually pretty
good it goes back to what i've
what i've been saying directors have a
certain half-life
they do yeah they're good when they're
young and they're trying to prove some
[ __ ] and they're real hungry and they
have a bunch of time to [ __ ]
fantasize about how the [ __ ] should be
shot after they [ __ ] made four or
five movies maybe
they started getting they started
getting lazy they just try to knock the
[ __ ] movie out
or in the case of guys like carpenter
carpenter made excellent movies and then
got shad on for his [ __ ] movies
so he's like all right [ __ ] you i'm just
going to make [ __ ] i'm just going to
make shitty babies
it doesn't matter if the movie's good or
not [ __ ] it that's that was the way
you can understand that because it's
like he made like a whole series of like
brilliant movies and everyone was like
meh
yeah yeah like they didn't really they
didn't really do that well and it's like
nobody really
and you know nobody wants to have to
like sit around until they're like old
and gray before people finally
appreciate their [ __ ] right
that's finally what happened to him but
he got [ __ ]
he did yeah you gotta [ __ ] a lot of
those guys and look at look you know
even like cameron james cameron you know
his word isn't really worth all that
much either he's come up with a lot of
[ __ ]
bad [ __ ] he was behind the only thing
good recently he was involved with was
elite a battle angel
and and i don't think he i think he just
kind of produced that
yeah i think he did much work on it uh
too bad we probably won't get a sequel
but that was a good one one of the best
movies of the year
i thought yeah i mean i feel like
you know in in a limited capacity it's
like if they just want to like put their
name on something and like give some
money toward it
you know to like maybe give it give it
some gravitas give it a little bit of
cache
yeah i mean that's pretty cool that's
true yeah that terminator dark fate was
[ __ ] bad
i just got it it wasn't that bad it was
just
fine it was just generic yeah it wasn't
great it wasn't
terrible it was just it was perfectly it
was a perfectly fine movie
that was the problem that's what i mean
that's the problem yeah it wasn't great
yeah but it wasn't horrible it was just
like just kind of forgettable yeah it
was just kind of forgettable and that
that's the problem
with [ __ ] terminator that shit's
supposed to be a [ __ ] excellent
[ __ ] movie
that you're gonna go oh man but the
problem is is there been so many bad
ones now
it's hard to [ __ ] you know
there's only there's only two good ones
one and two the rest of them you can
just
they're like you said they're just
forgettable three maybe
but not really and really some people go
like well
two is the best of all time t2
not really there's a lot of [ __ ] [ __ ]
that i didn't like about t2
the kid [ __ ] was obnoxious uh
the whole leather daddy [ __ ] angle of
[ __ ] him on the back with
you know just the to me it's just
it's just [ __ ] kind of wreaked a
pedestry i'm just going man
[ __ ] and it wasn't a horror movie
it's
terminator only works when it's arnold
schwarzenegger and he's the [ __ ]
villain that's what made that [ __ ] work
yeah because it was scary yeah that's
what made it that's the reason why you
remembered terminator one
because [ __ ] arnold man with a
[ __ ] machine gun
mowing people down inside a nightclub
all right
killing cops look mark came on and said
first again
get the [ __ ] out of here we're just
kidding
20 minutes late and say you're first
well
man that's the joke silence okay
don't really we're just kidding
that was [ __ ] fun i'm sitting here
[ __ ] talking talking [ __ ]
i got this [ __ ] class clown coming in
here saying first
okay i admit it is actually pretty funny
that's like some [ __ ] i would do
it is yeah didn't james cameron make a
few documentaries in the last
few years sandra asked yeah he did do
something about the
didn't you do something about the
titanic or something yeah yeah tammy
said he did a bunch on the titanic yeah
he was like
really interested in that kind of stuff
but yeah as l and like we said before i
was like really
um as we've been watching the stand like
over the last
few evenings i had forgotten how
actually really good it was
um even though it's funny because
stephen king um i guess he wanted
mcgarris to direct it because
mcgarris had directed stephen king's
sleepwalkers in 1992 even those
sleepwalkers
is kind of awful yeah
i love mcgarris though although
he was the one that came up with the
masters of horror series which i love
but the
the few episodes that he directed in
there i didn't really like him all that
much
he's like i love mick garris as a person
but he seems like um his directing is a
little
hit or miss but the stand seems really
good actually they're making a new one
um another series
that's supposed to be out later this
year right i don't know people in there
guys are agreeing agreeing with me that
t1 was it was the better one
look man this is the reason why t1 the
whole reason why t2 existed was on the
back of t1
i mean all right t1 with
what made t1 great is that it was a
[ __ ] horror movie it's basically jaws
it's a robot though yeah and it teased
you with so much [ __ ]
like it showed you the future and you
saw a little bit of it and that [ __ ]
didn't look good
all right and there's something about
not being shown
too much you know what i mean it was
better to see only a small amount of the
future
now t2 came out and i have to say that
that was a good movie but that was a
totally different kind of movie
that was an action movie well it was
almost kind of like the alien aliens
yeah thing very very much very similar
and for the same reasons i love both
those movies but i love alien one yeah
the most because it's more like it's a
horror movie it's not like an action
movie
i love aliens as well yeah alien one or
two i'd put them on par with each other
in greatness but they're they're two
different movies yeah one's
a [ __ ] action action action [ __ ]
thriller
and that's kind of the way t2 was t2 was
about [ __ ] big cars flipping over and
[ __ ] catching on fire and stuff [ __ ]
flying and trying to kill you
and [ __ ] uh trying to stop you know
and and arnie's in it
and he is the terminator but he's kind
of a good guy
which it works in the context of that
movie because he's replaced with another
terminator the liquid metal one
but there's something kind of
emasculating about when you tell the
[ __ ] arnie that he can't kill anybody
you know what i mean it the the it it
was kind of like
the [ __ ] terminator in a way he was it
took the threat out of it
and as we said i think that arnold
schwarzenegger arnold wanted that
play's a better villain yeah he's a bit
much better as a villain
you know i mean i'm not that's why he
didn't want to do it he knew that
i don't because he didn't he did it
you know it was probably the right
decision because he does you know
obviously he's still making movies
nowadays
but i do think that and i have seen
movies in him
where you know where he was the good guy
that i liked yeah
but namely predator one yeah like those
kind of movies
like but i do think that he really like
missed his calling
yeah because i think he just makes a
much scarier villain yeah
he does then he's more believable he is
yeah
now he was it worked in predator because
that was kind of like his personality
yeah i pretty much i pretty much own all
of arnie's catalog
even [ __ ] collateral damage which was
the worst movie of all [ __ ] times
i don't
[Laughter]
that was definitely the worst [ __ ]
arnold movie collateral damage was
[ __ ] terrible
all right his best one i'm gonna say his
best work is in predator one and i
i really [ __ ] i'm gonna credit
[ __ ] carl weathers
for that i think carl really pushed
arnold on
because carl kept [ __ ] [ __ ] with
him about not being able to act and yeah
he kept pushing himself
to do those scenes over and over and
over again and you can't just let arm
you just can't put arnold
you can't let him arnie
you can't cut him loose on a [ __ ]
sound stage or in a scene because he'll
just do whatever he wants to do and
people will let it happen
because it's horrible i'm like okay
all right that's the scene cut you know
you got to put another big [ __ ]
up there to go oh no no
no no no don't do that
yeah carl was the man for that there
should have been a lot more
carl and [ __ ] arnie team-ups in the
movies but it just didn't happen but
it should have been a lot more of them
after that movie man
carl came out with a [ __ ] movie
called action jackson and i [ __ ]
loved it i saw it in the thing i liked
that movie too
i just ought to get that on blu-ray
somebody send that [ __ ] to me
i'll write it down soon yeah write that
[ __ ] down action jackson jackson i have
to write everything i haven't seen it
forever i want to know if that [ __ ]
still
still holds up i remember liking it but
i haven't seen it when i saw carl
when i saw carl first of all i'm
watching man of lauren i don't know
nothing about it and i'm looking
wait wait wait a minute wait a minute
jenny was standing there she was sitting
there and i was like is that call
and she said yeah this car wasn't and i
said oh oh so
immediately yeah immediately immediately
man
lauren's [ __ ] status [ __ ] rose
that's okay
and he did a [ __ ] great job in the
mandalorian he was good in that i like
that yeah that's good
and in the second season he should still
should be in there
yeah nothing happened he didn't get
killed
and as a character that character is
worthy of carl
and carl's looking good he is actually
yeah he looked real good
you know and he's a he's an old man he
does not look that
he does not think that's good he really
does he's got to be
she's at least 20 years older than me
yeah i mean he's got to be in his 70s
yeah don't crack
that's what they say they just [ __ ]
keep on going
and a lot of guys you know that were
come on you know everybody knows carl
will tell you carl carl wasn't natural
carl was [ __ ] he was enhanced
and a lot of those guys come off that
gear they get real fat
and he didn't he still stayed in good
shape big upper body and everything he
looked good
yeah um actually arnold's not looking
that bad i saw a recent picture of him
walking around he he hit the gym again
he was looking a little rough for a
while
[Laughter]
because you know yeah changes you know
choo choo yeah well his heart's [ __ ]
up
yeah so he can't hit he can't hit the
gear and [ __ ]
sling a lot of iron like he used to kill
him so he's got to be real
you know i mean he's got to be real
[ __ ] gentle with himself
so he did build bill back some of that
weight
we'll see we'll see what he does yeah i
think he he's been talking about doing
king conan
or conan the king i don't know if it's
ever going to happen
i think the times for a conan movie are
gone i don't know if they could actually
do conan
anymore i don't know maybe not
yes we'll see how it goes conan's
[ __ ] not pc
it if it's pc it's just not [ __ ]
conan
dude who wrote that [ __ ] it's a big old
[ __ ] texan and he was [ __ ]
he wasn't crazy but he wasn't pc
you know alex ramirez said arnie went
through menopause he meant menopause
i went through menopause he also said i
still stand by twins arnold's finest
work
i've seen it i haven't i have but it's
been a very very long time i remember it
being funny but i don't know if i'd
still find it funny nowadays because
like i said i haven't
i've tried a very long time i tried to
get true lies on blu-ray they won't do a
blu-ray release they
didn't like the studio didn't like how
it portrayed
terrorists it's not
it's not on blu-ray not on blu-ray it's
not just on just on
um uh what do you call it dvd i got it
on dvd it looks good on dvd
yeah i like that movie but they won't do
a blu-ray release
bastards it was all right but michael
venture said arnold's best movie is
maggie that was actually that's pretty
dude that was a very very good movie
we have that as well i got it yeah he
did he did that was probably his best
acting i would say yeah i was actually
like really surprised
but that movie itself is a drama
it's i'm still gonna go lean towards
[ __ ] predator one
as arnold's best movie i'm just
you know that's just my opinion um i
think maggie is actually on 2b right now
for free if anybody wants to watch
it i think i remember seeing it on there
and then right there with [ __ ]
predator one maybe just a little bit
below it i mean just
barely a hair below it would be [ __ ]
terminator one
now here's another one man a lot of
people don't like this one jane's
getting bored because i'm talking about
arm
emperor arnold okay uh
there's another one i like i call it i
think was called like the fifth day or
something
fifth day or sixth day i think it's it's
about the clones
i think there's it came out 2000. i
liked that movie
you showed it to me it was all right it
was kind of like the last of the classic
arnold schwarzenegger movies
yeah you know like you know
i mean it felt like an arnie flick you
know derek newton says i recently
watched true lies this stunt doubling is
terrible
full of face shots where you can clearly
see it's not the actor it's like
watching the naked gun
yeah it wouldn't have mattered though it
wouldn't have mattered during that time
because most copies of it would have
been vhs on crt tv
you wouldn't [ __ ] been able to see it
clearly anyway
you could get away with a lot more back
then you could yeah because like
everything will just be fuzzy
i mean didn't you notice that that's not
arnold schwarzenegger being thrown
thrown around by the predator that's not
arnold
yeah you can clearly see that that's
sheen claude von tom
because he was he was a stunt dublin for
it yeah see [ __ ] vandals face
the side of his face getting tossed
because that guy in that predator suit
couldn't toss arnold
arnold was too big well yeah it's like i
can't throw that guy he's like
yeah but you know van damme's not very
big he could
he could he could toss him yeah yeah
yeah i mean van damme was and it was
more like a lean
yeah and it looked better on camera made
the predator look bigger
yeah so they put a smaller muscular guy
up next to him yeah actually that would
uh make a lot more sense
mixed arnold may make that monster look
a lot bigger
dom the bomb asks what did you think of
the latest rambo
i liked it yeah it was all right it was
pretty good actually i didn't think it
was as good as we saw in the theater
didn't we yeah we saw in the theater i
didn't need to buy that [ __ ]
um i got the uh the poster from the
theater too they were handing out free
posters yeah i got it
i got into my gym yeah um it was pretty
good
there's an extended cut i knew there was
an extended cut
but they're selling an extended club and
i'm hoping that it's got a scene where
he cuts that dude's head off
because remember he cut that one's
dude's head off and put it in yeah
that's right and i said why didn't they
show him cut that dude's head off so if
i was directing this [ __ ] i'd had a
scene of him cutting his head off well
i'm sure they probably did and then it
got
trimmed later because they didn't well
it was not as good i'm just going to be
honest man
i didn't like it as much as the fight
continues i think as well rambo five or
something whenever it is
that was like one of the most violent
movies so i enjoyed it very much
i also think his body's blowing up and
like [ __ ] arms and legs flying
i have to i have to revisit the
expendables i got all three of them
um sophie's coming down here the 18th
and yeah she wants to see him so i'll
i'll i'll save them for her when she
gets here
like all the all the rainbow movies no
expandables oh all the expendables maybe
yeah and here's the deal a lot of people
didn't like expendables 3 the theatrical
cut that they saw in the theater they
said it wasn't any good
uh and that had a lot to do with the
fact that [ __ ] was his name was in it
chuck norris was in it and you can't
cuss in a movie that has chuck norris
yeah he's he's got to stick up his butt
about
how when they so so i so they cut that
movie up into a piece of [ __ ] evidently
and it didn't really work too well but i
i never what was that me okay
i've never seen the theatrical cut i
have a
an expanded edition of it and this part
three was great
and that cussing and it had all kinds of
[ __ ] in it and well maybe they just said
after like chuck norris got off the side
they're like all right [ __ ] that [ __ ]
chuck
it's so funny because they're they're
trying to get [ __ ] steven seagal to
do from up before
and stephen's going yeah i'm not working
with those guys because he knows that if
he [ __ ] goes on that phone he's gonna
get called out they're gonna call him
out and make fun of his [ __ ] ass
this big old fat ass you know what they
should do
he probably sue them and rightfully so
yeah but they should take like clips
from some of his other like direct to
dvd movies and like splice them in there
because all you you wouldn't have to
like even do anything well no because
you don't need him to be there because
he wouldn't be there anyway he would
just be like sitting there
so it's like they could just cut away to
him like sitting there and like
looking around and just like look he's
in the movie why the [ __ ] would steven
seagal be in your movie he's not even in
his own movies
he's probably he's like you know he's
got peons to do that [ __ ] for him yeah
he's sitting back at his place in russia
drinking that asian experience
and he knows or whatever's
he's gonna come to our house and beat us
up so no i was just gonna say because
you're not allowed to swear around chuck
norris so i guess pro tip we can't ever
have
chuck norris over for dinner because i
won't be able to talk at all
i'm sure he's not i'm sure he'll like
not be worried
all right donald's telling me that uh
rambo the fight continues with number
four all right um
let's see yeah
it does yeah he also has a bad wig
yeah we're so we were watching while we
were watching the stand the guy that
played
i didn't know this either but they uh
they went through a lot of different
people like um
for who they who should play randall
flag most of the people they wanted
they actually wanted uh christopher
walken or
jeff goldblum or david bowie which
actually would have been interesting
for what uh for randall flagg in the
stand
but um none of them were available so
they ended up with the guy that they got
and it's just like i hate to say but the
guy's hair
in this it's like when i first saw him
from the back and i had forgotten all
about it and i was like oh my god the
mullet and i was like
he looks like eddie money yeah and for
what's funniest
the whole time i've been calling him
eddie in the book he was described as
that though
i know that's true they got it good
[ __ ] mullet and [ __ ] yeah they they
got it
yeah it's just funny to see it i think
it was a poor choice for a movie though
yeah i would have made him look like
that yeah because like i said he's not
he's not real threat it's not real
threatening when it's just like looks
like
age will some [ __ ] kicker dudes i'm just
like take me home tonight
i'm the evil guy in the movie stephen
king
stephen stephen king's idea of badassery
didn't always work out
it did but again he would he would put
some characters in in books that he
thought were real badasses like [ __ ]
mafioso guys and
they would just say and do [ __ ] that
just wasn't that badass
you know sorry sir you're just not that
badass yeah
he's not his dialogue his dialogue is
real [ __ ] wannabe
you know uh but he does it's just drugs
drugs and not being around too much and
his [ __ ]
dialogue for the black characters is
[ __ ] laughable sometimes
just gotta say i well yeah i guess so
gotta say well i said i really like um
like the lady that plays abigail
and like mother abigail in this ruby d
she came out and she was actually
married to ozzy davis at the time who
was in this uh also he was also in bubba
hotel which he reviewed a while back
among millions of other things that he
was in but um she apparently really
wanted this role because she's like this
is
you know i i've spent my whole life like
doing even though i was just like oh my
god
well i'm not talking about this movie in
particular yeah i'll be talking about
just in general his dialogue for
black people and his dialect because he
he has a lot of them in a lot of even
the short stories
yeah and his dialogue for southerners
and his the in his portrayal of
southerners
is obviously somebody who's never been
to the south well i
the thing about stephen king though is
that
even a lot of the characters that are
from maine which is where most of his
characters are
a lot of them a little bit on the
caricature side yeah i think
yeah um he's a stereotyping [ __ ]
that's what he does
you know what i mean which but but i but
he's done it over so many books that
that's like kind of
his hallmark so it doesn't bother me as
much anymore in his books i guess
it is but it's like like i said even
like his main characters
that you know that are from the
northeast or whatever um
some of them come across like with their
weird like little
witticisms and stuff like that it's like
i don't know if anybody really talks
like that yeah he's imagining them
talking like that i think
i mean i don't know it is it's hard to
write dialogue that sounds realistic
but you know who am i to question the
[ __ ] he's a multi-millionaire
well yeah and like zillions of people
all over the world read his books so
it's like
although i'm sure he really let's be
honest i'm gonna be honest you're gonna
be honest we can all be honest together
that sounded like a song a lot of times
a lot of times it's the right man in the
right place at the right time
if if if stephen king were to appear
right now
as a 20 year old with those books on in
today's market
you wouldn't notice him probably there's
a lot of them like that
although they're the fact that there's a
lot of them like that is because
he came out back then no like everybody
you know i'm just saying there's a lot
of young guys writing [ __ ] i don't
think he would stand out in the crowd
no probably not is because back in those
days you know what i mean everything was
filtered
through a media of printers and a bunch
of agents and [ __ ]
they were deciding what people were
gonna get if you [ __ ] had a contract
with
with the publisher and the book sold
real well you'd get another one and
another one and another one and it would
build you up in a superstar
it doesn't happen today everything's
[ __ ] you know what i mean
everything's off amazon yeah
you know and a lot of [ __ ]
self-published
uh because why do you want a middle man
you make more profit if you just do it
yourself
well it's very difficult to become a
[ __ ] superstar that way
because you don't have big corporations
behind you
pushing your material for you yeah they
don't like have big promotions budgets
right because i think that's that's what
did what did it and
and even nowadays like if you have the
money to like actually promote yourself
yeah you're gonna get far
whether you're self-published or not but
it's like if you don't really have that
money then you just kind of have to
maybe you'll get lucky and somebody will
notice how awesome your [ __ ] is but
maybe you won't
you know most of us direct sell like
what we do yeah this is the way it's
gonna be in the future
but like you said if you somehow
why would you spend a million dollars in
advertisement for a book you probably
wouldn't get a return
if you look right now what you would do
is just so i can have somebody videotape
you doing something [ __ ] crazy and
then you go viral and then they sell
your books off that
yes that's how the average person would
do it today
yeah just make a youtube video doing
something yeah like walking up and
smacking a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
that woman who wrote harry potter right
i get you on camera just walking up to
her and just slap it or pop it
and then we'll post and then the cops
[ __ ] grabbing you
and [ __ ] like that and i'll post that
[ __ ] up might be worth it and then it'll
be like you know
yeah yeah you'd immediately [ __ ] sell
millions of dollars with the [ __ ]
copies
mark says success is mostly luck and
dong size
yeah well i guess i'm [ __ ] then
i come up a little bit higher
[Laughter]
how long have we been on for christ's
sake long time for 40 minutes for
somebody that didn't have anything to
talk about but yeah so
i don't know was it but i'm i'm really
uh enjoying watching this
re-watching the stand i've i'll have to
reread the book i don't i haven't read
the book since i was
[ __ ] 17 or 18 years old it was a long
time ago
i think i have it somewhere but i don't
have the um because didn't he
as long as that [ __ ] book is i think
i have like the original
um the paperback version and didn't he
do like an extended version which is
like [ __ ] 700 more pages because he
just can't stop himself
as if you need more of that book
you don't need more of that but sorry i
just thought of a quote from mystery
science theater
like we're like you're so cool we need
more of you yeah but yes
really you know one of king's best books
i thought
was the one he did peter straub the
[ __ ] talisman the talisman i really
liked that one i would be interested to
see that filmed
yeah they he did uh they did a follow-up
to that
the black house i think but i don't
think i ever read
it not that i remember um my i don't
know it's hard for me to pick i probably
like i mean the shining
pet cemetery uh was a really good book
i mean i read that in high school and i
just [ __ ] loved that book
the one of his that i've read the most
weirdly is his nonfiction one
dance macabre which is all about horror
from the 50s to the 80s
it's fascinating like all the [ __ ] about
literature and movies and tv shows and
like stuff like that and he's like
really insightful about
what's scary and like what you know like
he's really he's good well he was an
english teacher for a long time
so he's good at um kind of breaking down
the themes and like all these novels and
stuff and i found that really
interesting but i've read that like a
[ __ ] ton of times
and i like his short stories as well you
know yeah
he has that program um
dollar babies he has a website and you
can go on there and if you're gonna make
a
like a short film you can option the
rights to some of his
short stories for a buck and you have
them for like a year or a year and a
half or something like that but you have
to make a
film out of it you can't just like do it
for the [ __ ] of it and it has to be a
short film
and i don't think you can make money off
it or something but it's just like for
students you know
another one besides stephen king while
you're reading all that you know
king was cool he wrote big old books i
was also into the little
pulp series novel series one of them i
was into was called
traveler i tell you about that one i
don't think so
traveler was [ __ ] about about a
future post-apocalyptic
america and it was kind of like he was
it was an army ranger guy
who was um and it was supposed to be
taking place in the 90s
all right late 90s
um he was like mad max he'd run around
in a [ __ ]
van he had lined with bulletproof vests
and had the thing fully equipped with
like a
an engine that would burn [ __ ] oil it
was a
rotary engine he had it all linked up
where he could run it on vegetable oil
or whatever
and uh it was he was fighting
desert dudes and you know like desert
[ __ ] wastelanders
and then it turns out as the story
unfolds there's [ __ ] mutants
and biological experiments and [ __ ] and
monsters
cats and dogs it got more and more
bizarre as it went and it got [ __ ]
better
you know as back when you'd be in high
school you smoked some weed and read
that [ __ ]
oh yeah oh yeah there's a lot of sex in
it
well you know you like yeah
audience and everything he eventually
links up with this dude called
lynx who's a [ __ ] he links up with
link yeah yeah
and he's a genetically engineered
[ __ ] lynx a cat
he's bipedal and he could talk and he
was he was made
he got let out of a [ __ ] research
facility
and he was cool he could talk he didn't
wear clothes or anything but he could
jump around he could use
guns and even get laid
he'd screw him man so that was like kind
of ahead of his way
because that's like a huge erotica yeah
category yeah and like all the girls
liked him it's like where animal
types yeah traveler get pissed off in
fact what his real name was
he's been watching that he's like god
damn he was the next sergeant guy yeah
hat man's getting late yeah he can't
steal all the girls and [ __ ] catman he's
like damn you know what i mean he's like
hey good man's got to do he's got to do
you know kind of [ __ ] you know cat's
gonna do it
yeah yeah right yeah they were don't
hate the player
you're fighting these things called send
cars
a sin car was a living car that had a
[ __ ] torso on the top of it and it
was [ __ ] armored like a transformer
yeah it had bone on the outside of it
nice and the wheels [ __ ] did roll
but they were stuffed squishy wheels
with [ __ ]
like rubberized [ __ ] cartilage around
the outside of it
and they didn't need any fuel so he was
having mad max [ __ ] chases with
[ __ ] living cars
and the cars were throwing boulders and
[ __ ] at him you know they couldn't talk
or anything they were they were kind of
idiots
it's all kinds of [ __ ] weird [ __ ] was
happening so many good drugs back then
you guys
yeah i bet you i bet you that series is
still out there it's called
it might be a traveler and then
something another wanderer of the
wasteland or something
saunders says uh i like stephen king's
on writing i liked that as well
that actually really really helped me
out a lot um a lot of it is
it you know i it was kind of interesting
because a lot of his like
autobiographical but he does actually
give like a really lot of good
writing advice in there without being
like obnoxious about it
and uh yeah i actually found it really
helpful i wouldn't mind like reading
that again
i have a bunch of his books but like i
said i think the newest one of his that
i read was
under the dome which was good but i
don't really remember much about it
like i think his old stuff was better
khan's out there saying that it sounded
like what i'm talking about sounds like
damnation alley it kind of was like damn
nationality crosstalking damn
nationality and mad max
yeah pretty cool yeah it's out there i
imagine you could probably still get it
yeah you probably can't you're a good
book because all that stuff i mean
people remember that [ __ ] fondly so it's
like yeah you know
a lot of shit's getting and actually i
was uh when i was doing one of my book
reviews the other day for a book from
1981 that was like a southern gothic
like horror story
um a lot of the like paperback
pulp originals like from the 70s and 80s
and stuff um
are being republished because i guess
they've like found a new audience
like among younger people so they're
publishing like all the best ones
tammy says did anybody read the stephen
king's short story the long walk
yeah that was that's a really good one
actually that whole uh the bachmann
books
that had um that was the one that had
rage
and the long walk and uh the [ __ ]
what was the one with the [ __ ] movie
they made with arnold schwarzenegger the
game show
the running man that had that in it and
uh another good already movie yeah one
more but i can't remember
but um yeah the long walk was actually
really good i
i heard that they were adapting i mean
they say that about every stephen king
thing but i heard they were adapting
that into a movie i'm like
that would probably be a good movie but
it's not i mean it's not real
action-packed it's just like people
walking but it's like it's kind of like
a horrible like
i liked i liked uh the running man movie
yeah with arnold in there there's
another good arnold movie the problem is
is a lot of that movie ended up on the
cutting room floor that's it
did you know that yeah because there's
there was a lot more action and fighting
in it originally but they couldn't get
it they couldn't get the rating where
they wanted it they just kept cutting
and cut it and cutting it
and it was really if you look at there's
there's hardly any fighting in the
goddamn thing
yeah each little fight tastes like it
tastes like two seconds
yeah it's mostly just dudes like going
in yeah
[ __ ] they had to cut it all out i mean
too bad there's no way to restore that
movie
yeah basically i mean they probably
could but usually
i mean a lot of times back then they
didn't really save and save
like after they cut it out the clippings
the clips like the toenail clippings
yeah from the movies sometimes they do
find them later on like if somebody
thinks to keep them
especially if like the director was like
man [ __ ] i don't want him to cut
all this [ __ ] out of my movie and i'm
gonna keep it in my garage yeah
or whatever i would love to see what it
was originally look like
yeah yeah connor vatsalon says that the
traveler is an eight book series
and it is uh on sale on amazon okay all
right yeah
it's the future you can get anything you
want i thought there i thought there was
more than eight books
though maybe it was only eight i thought
it was more like 15
20 of them seemed to go on forever maybe
it was only eight
everything seemed to go on forever
[Laughter]
all right you done yeah i'm done all
right
so uh yeah we'll be back on another live
stream tomorrow probably do another
review because i want to
watch a new one there's a new one that
just dropped on netflix that i might
want to watch that we can review
tomorrow
same time same place so uh thanks
everybody for dropping by and we'll see
you guys again tomorrow
bye